hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer setup the epic
stakes for the final six episodes of the
series but one major character the show
keeps leaving out its ghost Jon's dire
wolf arias dire wolf and I'm Maria got a
major appearance at season 7 the ghost
was ghost
now ghost is supposed to play a major
role in this final season according to
crew and if you look closely at this
trailer he may actually have been hiding
in plain sight I'm gonna explain where
and what role the surviving direwolves
could play in this final season the game
of Thrones
spoiler warning in case any my theories
end up being right and they ruin your
life okay if you watch this trailer as
many dozens of times as I have there are
actually a few places ghost or nine area
could have appeared the one I pointed
out in my trailer breakdown was this
shot of course is charging through the
snow you look closely you can see what
look like shorter white legs along with
some shaggy ER looking white or gray fur
it's not confirmed but this could be a
sign of the dire wolves will play a role
in the Battle of Winterfell like perhaps
part of Jon's cavalry charge against the
dead or maybe your I mean last minute to
save their asses
I honestly think a lot of different
non-human creatures will factor into
this battle we know the army of the Dead
includes a resurrected dragon as well as
resurrected Giants and we saw how
effective Giants could be at breaching
the gates of Winterfell they also have
corpse bears and according to old man
and various legends giant ice spiders
like there's that shot and the trailer
when Ari had cuts through something that
spews out a good amount of blood or
fluid it's gonna be a beastly battle the
director of the Battle of Winterfell
Miguel so poached NYX said that he was
inspired by Lord of the Rings battles
like helms deep and existential battles
and fantasy worlds like this one
typically do feature a number of fantasy
creatures beyond humans and along with
John and Danny using their two dragons I
think they're gonna use every beast that
they can including the direwolf ghost if
they can get them he's apparently real
busy these days but where else could
ghosts be hiding in this trailer
some of you pointed out the shots of the
Winterfell crypts but that direwolf is a
statue of a direwolf as many old stark
graves have direwolf statues
accompanying them some others pointed
out that shot of Jon in the Winterfell
godswood saying ghost is in the
background but that is a bush but then
right at the end of the trailer as Sir
Jorah Mormont stares down the coming
enemy there definitely is
some Lightford animal moving behind him
now this could be a worse as we did see
some Dothraki right in pale horses
behind Jorah earlier but it's hard to
tell if this thing is the same height as
a horse or if there's any rider on its
back the effects supervisor Joe Bauer
promised in an interview that we would
see ghosts again that he has a fair
amount of screen time in season eight
and that he's very present and does some
pretty cool things the tiger wolves were
a very big part of the show in season
one but over time the animals have
played a smaller and smaller role
largely because their immense size makes
them difficult visual effects to produce
and I guess the show would rather spend
that money on dragons in the books the
dire wolves carry a much deeper
importance to the narrative and the
corresponding six dire wolf pups
discovered at the beginning of the story
share a thematic parallel with the stark
children like we know bran is a warg a
person who can share their consciousness
with an animal seen through that
animal's eyes in controlling animals
actions like he sees through the eyes of
his direwolf summer and he hunts through
him and in the books that's hinted that
the other Starks Cera warg like
connection with their dire wolves to
John and Arya both dreamed from the
perspective of their dire wolves and
although we never get a point of view
chapter from Robb there are some clues
like he was described as being in a
trance-like state at one point not
responding to questions as he's just
stared vacantly at a map and on the
battlefield witnesses talked about a
strange connection between the boy and
the wolf as if they shared the same mind
and that's what made him so effective in
battle Sansa star wolf lady was killed
off early on and we don't really know if
Rickon had any connection to shaggy dog
but george RR martin did say years
before the show came out that he had in
his notes that all the stark kids could
be wargs Ned told bran at the beginning
of all this that House Stark descends
from the first men and one theory is
that their bloodline gives them the
power to warg like looking back into the
history of Westeros shortly after a long
night ancient starts defeated a figure
known as the warg king they killed his
sons and they married his daughters into
their family suggesting this could have
been the origin of the war trait within
the stark bloodline perhaps several
generations of Starks simply didn't know
they had this ability though Lyanna
stark did have a unique connection with
horses many described her as the best
horse rider in Westeros
but whether or not genetics are part of
this George R Martin has implied that
they aren't the rules definitely changed
with the arrival of the dire wolf pups
dire wolves are magical creatures that
hadn't been seen south of the walls so
much so that they were considered by
many to be a myth some believed that
along with the rebirth of the Dragons
reflected a reawakening of magic within
the world of Westeros allowing this
latest generation of Starks to connect
with their dire wolves now again this
HBO series has largely done away with
this whole dire wolves backstory really
in the show the dire wolves aren't much
more than loyal furry companions and
most spirit animals but there have been
some hints that there's something more
there remember
when lady Melisandre resurrected Jon
ghost since his return slightly before
he woke up and these cool things that
the VFX team promised for ghosts may go
beyond them just tearing through whites
at the Battle of Winterfell like it
could involve a reunion with the other
surviving direwolf Nymeria in a Clash of
Kings John and Arya's wolf dreams
suggest that ghosts in I'm area could be
calling out to each other they're lonely
howls echoing across Westeros
now I'm areas recent return in season
seven suggested that she had no interest
in returning to Winterfell
turning away with her new pack when arya
begged her to go home with her in this
moment arya realized a new
interpretation of her father's words
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
if i marry a joint arabic of Winterfell
Nymeria would be a pet again but now
nine area leads her own path and I could
see that pack returning to help Aria and
the other Starks and I marry his brother
ghost in the Battle of Winterfell in
season eight or to go a little tin foil
a dead Nymeria resurrected by the night
king could return to attack Arya and
potentially set up a showdown between
the living ghost in the dead Nymeria
move ball and this would parallel other
sibling battles between the living
drogon and regal in the dead Vaziri on
and the living Hound in the dead
resurrected sort of mountain or maybe
Nymeria could inspire Arya to just leave
this battlefront altogether in search of
her own pack whether or not humanity
wins the day against the dead just
doesn't really seem like arias core
mission right there has been much
speculation over what arias ultimate
destiny is but I think the direwolves
biggest influence on this final season
of Game of Thrones could be to inspire
these
kids to seek their own packs even when
that could mean going rogue from the
pack that they were born into what role
do you want ghost to play in the final
season comment down below with your
thoughts
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @ ee
vas and subscribe to this channel for
more game of Thrones analysis and
theories thank you for watching and hold
on to those buds because wolf ball 2019
yes
[Music]